[Music]
pop quiz hotshot you're in Harlem and
you're at this building you go through
the door enter the security code take
the elevator to the third floor knock on
this door where Rudy greets you hi and
welcome you make your way into a packed
apartment and try to find a seat what do
you get you get a live jazz performance
like no other
[Music]
every Sunday Marjorie Elliot and her son
Rudel drear's open the doors to their
apartment for people to come and listen
to jazz music we decided to use our
apartment because we can do what we want
here the system matter of this is home
so everybody who walks through that door
we treat his family and it's a pretty
big family the concerts are so popular
that if you're not on time finding a
seat can be a little tricky we fill up
the living room the kitchen hallway
people will stand out taking videos it's
pretty much like that every Sunday now
you know it's like it's jam-packed
the jazz concerts began in 1993 after
rudel's brother Phil passed away well my
brother passed away on a Sunday and
whelming had the great idea to honor him
with concerts on Sundays you know when
you play music you just get all your
angst out and it's just a healing
feeling so I think our thing was you
know what better way to honor him and
with the concert and we've been blessed
to never Evans to Sunday with their
commitment and consistency to play every
Sunday the concerts are now considered
legendary in Harlem attracting audiences
from all over the world
hey Rudel do you mind if we ask some of
the audience members where they came
from
of course I'm from Germany France
Australia Kuran yeah that's pretty cool
I think once we started it just took on
a life force of its own sometimes people
come and they just they don't know what
they're gonna expect you know it's like
Ringo Dell and get free jazz and then
once they get here they have that
experience it's kind of something they
won't forget
[Music]
[Applause]
for some people this is their church you
will come here and I feel renewed and we
feel renewed and you never know when
you're gonna touch out there so you're
putting out good energy it's gonna work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
blues is a feeling and it is in
experience blues is about something that
happens in my life my name is Beverly
Watkins I was born here in Atlanta
Georgia in 1939 Beverly Watkins was a
pioneer for women in blues when I was
playing back in the sixties there wasn't
no female guitar players not in Georgia
they said I play like a man but they're
using the wrong terminology the main
thing is because I play so good after
high school
Beverly began touring with the band
piano red and the meter toads shortly
thereafter she was opening for some of
the biggest acts in music we opened up
for James Brown VB teen Otis Redding I
played over two or three thousand shows
back in those days the artists took time
and hope each other
her hard classic blues style has evolved
over the last 60 years touring with
different bands and eventually going
solo
I never stopped when they said I should
I didn't pay him no mind I kept going
yes it has gotten hard out there you
know I clean houses I worked at car
washes I clean offices but I never
stopped playing my music
and she has no plans on stopping anytime
soon well into her 70s she still puts on
a show for the crowd
it is keeping me living keeping me gone
I'm gonna look good and have a good time
and get up there and do my thing
[Music]
when it come to ride with Bilbo walk
ain't nothing he can't do with a gift
that's why nobody never been able to
kick up his ties and things that I got
robbed a billboard walk and I'm a legend
of the blue not always from a little boy
I love I want to be looking I want
everybody looking at me I wanted to beat
one of the guys that everybody said dad
healed that's what inspired me to read
it make me want to be a musician
the cool thing about build a walker is
that he grew up in the same Mississippi
Delta blues environment is like Charlie
Patton or Robert Johnson or Muddy Waters
or Halle wolf or BB King and when he
performs it feels like that is like a
living fossil
[Music]
this is one little icy it's not radon
nightclub it's more like a juke joint is
what two people live down in Mississippi
it's out there in the boonies not even a
town it's just out in a field and I also
love the fact that it's just so hard to
find right till your edit I didn't want
open in town because I only got two
minute
I didn't we got no roof from the ground
or from stretch that's right we built in
here and put it on the ground
it's an old army barracks Quonset hut
cutting pieces moved on his property
himself real authentic juke joint is
gonna be african-american owned because
it comes out of that culture and it's
gonna probably have a big personality
behind it this is seven years I've been
understand but it wouldn't have took
that long footage kept getting robbed
need a fluid come in got it you got
nothing in this place that makes you
won't just want to give up then I got
ambition about everything inside I said
no I'm not going I'm gonna give him one
more chance
[Music]
real juke joints that are still
operating with live music I can probably
count on one hand I used to say you know
you just you're not gonna get any more
juke joints like that I would have to
say Bilbo's just gets grandfathered in
it's just such a real thing and it's
kind of an extension of him and sort of
what he's been doing his whole life I
[Music]
wanted to be something that people to
remember me for see all to make people's
love you like that you got to be
different I wanted to come as famous and
then it's crazy ever been in the war
[Music]
Bessy Olive Sally and Jess have one big
thing in common they all love jazz
[Music]
this is Live Oak Florida a small town
west of Jacksonville not the type of
place you associate with jazz and yet
there's ed I'm a dairy farmer here in
north Florida home to about 6800 cows
that it he can really blow
he's been playing trombone since
elementary school but his audience has
changed this is his story the first time
I can remember the cows coming up is I
was just standing out in the backyard
and playing a trombone and all the cows
came up to the fence
I had a full audience they're not
particularly critical either cows are
very much creatures of habit the music
is something that's out of the norm and
that's why they're entertained the cows
have a inability to understand what's
threatening and what squeezing and music
is definitely pleasing cool
and I have no idea if it's the 1/2 per
heard the music and the rest of them are
following the other effort but it really
doesn't matter at the end of the day
we're all having a good time my dad told
me when we were kids he said it's
important from day one how we take care
of animals and we like to consider
ourselves good stewards of the land good
stewards of the animals playing the
trombone is not any different than going
out and how we feed our cows and we take
care of our cows it's all about our
interaction with these animals our
animals they care and so you play music
to them they will remember that
[Music]
it's November 6th 1814 in the belgian
city of de Nantes and a modest house
built on a street that would later bear
his name
Adolphe Sax was born 28 years later
while living in Paris Sachs would invent
the saxophone and revolutionized music
in ways he couldn't imagine but this
isn't that story this is the story of
how a tough sax escaped death seven
times before mending the saxophone
hardly old enough to stand the young
Adolf fell down three flights of stairs
stone floor broke his fall the age of
3/8 off swallowed a bowl of water down
sulfuric acid mistaking it for milk
years later Adolf and him talk up a bit
too close to a gunpowder explosion he
was again burned when a cast-iron frying
pan was knocked over under later a roof
stone fell on his head leaving a
lifelong scar a tough once nearly
asphyxiated and when recently varnished
items were left in his bedroom overnight
he woke up barely playing with friends
in a nearby river Adolf was swept up in
a swift current and nearly drowned again
he survived
[Music]
On February 7th 1894 a dog died
peacefully in Paris
saxophone had already crossed the
Atlantic Prime to evolve into an icon of
American jazz music and guarantying sax
his immortality I never thought in a
million years that I would be here in
Japan singing the music that my
grandmother introduced me to I'm a
testament to say that no matter how big
your dreams are they can definitely be
achieved
[Music]
a boca no home yoga jeido Hawaii Kona
Eskimo gave me a jet all day in Kakaako
[Music]
anka is a form of Japanese music so it's
only sung in Japan it is considered an
older genre of music I call it Japanese
blues because all of the lyrics are very
sad melodramatic they often talk about
lost loves and heartbreak it uses a lot
of imagination it really doesn't spell
out the meaning of the song for you so
everyone who listens to the music can
have their own interpretation I was born
and raised in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania my
grandmother she was originally from
Yokohama I basically went to my
grandmother's house just about every
weekend she listened to think music all
the time I think it was a way for her to
keep Japan in her heart even while she
was living in the US I started singing
around five years old my grandmother
would always say you sing so well good
to see a smile on her face would just
brighten my day because I loved her so
much because I had so much love for ANCA
and wanted to know what the lyrics I was
singing meant I started studying
Japanese in high school and throughout
college and was always interested in
Japan and where my mom and my
grandmother came from so I moved to
Japan to become an Enka singer
[Music]
the very first time I stood on the stage
in st. port crowd was actually on TV
kind of like American Idol I was given
so much praise and it made me feel
really really good they were just so
surprised like why would
twenty-something American be listening
to a jar like this and it kind of worked
in my favor I started singing
professionally in 2008 there's never
been an American who's been on stage
singing Anka professionally here in
Japan I've had the opportunity to do
different types of songs children's
songs musicals TV dramas I think I've
been really embraced wholeheartedly from
the Japanese audience me singing Anka
really was a way for me to connect to
Japan and connect with my grandmother
and to this day the love I have for Anka
has not changed
[Applause]
you
[Music]